نحن نتواجد في منطقه مشروع بيت لاهيه هذه
المنطقه التي تعرضت لقصف عنيف واحزمه
ناريه خلال هذه الحرب تم تدمير عدد كبير
من المنازل في هذه المنطقه هنا بدا
الاهالي بالعوده لهذه المنطقه بعد مده
طويله من الخروج بعد هذا الدمار الذي حل
بهذه المنطقه هنا الاهالي لم يجدوا اي
ماوى لهم ولم يجدوا اي منزل صالح للسكن
قرروا عمل خيام هنا بين ركام المنازل وفوق
ركام المنازل بسبب عدم توفر اي ماو لهم
هنا في شمال قطاع غزه شي احنا طلعنا من
المنطقه هذه قصرا طلعونا من المدارس
ونجحنا لغزه وبعد تقريبا 17 يوم 18 يوم
رجعنا للمنطقه لقينا المنطقه دمار شامل
يعني البيوت هنا كله هيتها عندك من عند
جامع صلاح الشحاده لعند ابو صفيه مفخخه
البيوت تفخيخ كليتها يعني عمل ليه تخريب
كامل عشان الناس ما تقدر ترجع لبيوتها
وهينا قاعدين بنصب خيمه وبنصب خيمه فوق
البيت بس عشان نقدر نلاقي ماوى في ظل
هالبرد القارص هذا غير عن الجوع لحتى الان
كيس الطحين ما دخل عنا على الشمال من اول
يوم الهدن لحتى انا ما دخلش يعني نفذت
المواد الغذائيه بالكامل نهائيا يعني
الحين احنا بنعيش شوء حقيقي وطلع صورته
يعني مساحه يمكن فوق ال 700 متر على
اليمين وعلى الشمال فيش بيوت في مشروع بيت
لها يعني نهائيا فيش بيوت فش اننا ماوى
ثاني فش مكان ثاني نروح له يعني الجنوب
خطر ما فيش اضطرينا نرجع لمكان بيوتنا
اللي احنا في الاساس كنا ساكنين فيها وهي
الخيمه هي قاعدين بنصب فيها قاعدين هينا
حطينا زينجو حطينا مواسير ايش بدنا نعمل
بدنا نقدر قد ما نقدر نضلنا في منطقتنا و
في بلدنا ساكنين في المنطقه اللي احنا
تربينا فيها يعني العدو الصهيوني قام بهدم
ونسف المربع بشكل كامل وقمنا على اساس انه
نحن ما لنا مكان ولا ماوى بنينا عريش زي
ما انت شايف واغلب الجيران يعني قاعدين
بيبنوا عرايش او اماكن يعني فوق يعني
بالواح الصفيح بجمعها من بقايا انقاضه وبن
بعدلها زي ما انت شايف وبعد ما نعدلها
بنعمل مكان عشان نقوي اليه عشان يعني نامن
اولادنا وانفسنا من برد الشتاء والامطار
اللي انت شايفها وفيش لنا مكان ولا ماوى
نروح عليه يعني زي ما انت شايف انه دمار
وجوع وعط والناس مش قادره تامن لاولادها
قووت يومها الوضع يعني مزري والله يعين
الناس على حالها والحمد لله على كل حال
كنت موجود في اماكن الاواء في المدارس
اواء اللاجئين طبعا بتوفر ولا شيء هناك
وفي نفس الوقت في امراض مرض الكبد الوبائي
طبعا اصيب بعض اولادي بالعدوى فاضطريت انه
انا اطلع من المدرسه والجا لان اقوم ببناء
المعرش اللي انت شايفه هذا عشان اقعد فيه
فوق بيتي يعني الواحد برتاح ويامن نفسه
وبكون في من عن الامراض والاخطار يعني
احنا احنا متشبثين بارضنا وفيش امكانيه
يعني نغادر من هذا المكان وهذا هذه ارضنا
وان شاء الله سنبقى هنا رغم كل شيء ان شاء
الله يعطيكم العافيه الله
يعافيك نعمل خيمه زي ما انت شايف احنا
وباقي هال
الجيران
مش خطر عليك ولا خطر ولا حاجه ربنا سلم ان
شاء
الله ما فيش مكان نسكن خلونا مكان نسكن
فيه بنعمل بنا نضبط وندب حالنا نعيش ايش
بدنا
نسوي صامدون ولن نرحل كلمات خطها الاهالي
هنا فوق ركام هذا المنزل رغم الدمار الذي
حل بهم الا انهم مازالوا يصرون على البقاء
وعدم
الرحيل انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه